這陣子Gemini默默混進了Google的各大服務
很多人可能沒有發覺自己早就已經被AI偷偷升級了
今天這集就要帶你
一一揪出常在Google生態系各個角落的Gemini雙子座
AI斜杠新手村的早鳥優惠雖然說結束 但是為了回饋大家對泛科學院的支持
我們呢 決定6折優惠直接延長
抽獎活動也照常舉行
還沒有入手的 趕外找同事親友一起沖一波吧
這波抽獎看半年的GPT點數還在等你
嗨各位又是我AJ
有些人可能已經發現了Gemini這個雙子星符號 現在非常的不安分守己
除了在右上角的選單內還有直接搜尋之外呢
他不時都會潛伏在一些以往沒有出現的地方
沒錯
Google從去年開始把Gemini一直持續不斷的對Google的用戶去做一些AB 測試 釋出
到了現在有越來越多的Gemini出現在Google的生態系里面
今天這集影片我們就要跟大家一起來盤點一下現在Gemini又出現在哪邊
讓你直接內建AI模型外掛 用好用滿
另外我們要先感謝所有加入泛科同學還有泛科學長姐的朋友
有你們的支持泛科學院才能一直不斷的升級內容
當然如果你有什麽AI主題想看 想學
隨時在會員的留言區許願
我們都會去參考
另外提醒還沒有加入的朋友
加入之後每個月還會送你990的課程折扣碼 還有專屬的會員影片
趕快加入一起解鎖更多AI知識吧
好那第一個地方在哪里呢
躲在google瀏覽器的這個搜尋里面
你只要按小老鼠你就可以找到Gemini了
那我就可以直接問他問題比如說google io會發表什麽內容呢
你看Gemini就開始搜尋了
他說google發表會在5月20 21在美國山景城
然後呢 你就會看到有新的東西 有的沒的
所以這個其實就是你直接使用Gemini的網頁版然後直接問他問題
只是他現在躲在Google的瀏覽器里面
一個小老鼠就可以叫Gemini出來直接回答你問題
那我們自己在測試的時候 其實還遇到一些小狀況
有些人的google瀏覽器打了小老鼠之後Gemini叫不出來
我們猜測有可能是因為你的賬號還沒有被Google選定做AB測試
就是你的功能還沒有被開通
那可能的解法 你可以試著把你的賬號切換成英文模式
那這樣子你就會有機會開通這個在Gemini
直接在google瀏覽器里面搜尋的這個AI搜尋的功能
第二個位置在哪里呢
我們打開一個很簡單的gmail的收件夾
然後剛好有一封信進來
AJ老師要外派
什麽外派
假的 假的
我沒有馬上立即要去上課 但當你收到一封信件的時候
現在Gemini會這個這個雙子座的星星 出現在這邊可以幫你總結這封電子郵件
那你就可以按一下它
他就幫你總結
可是 我不知道為什麽總結 他不會總結成中文的
所以你可以跟他講說 請幫我翻譯成中文
所以這個是第二個
那其實我們有觀察那個更有趣的現象 就是這個總結電子郵件呢
不是每封郵件都會出現
比如說 我們可以去看看一些其他的信件
比如說這
看沒有出現
然後什麽 好這個沒有出現
然後這個
沒有出現 出現不出現這是個謎 如果有出現他覺得你需要信件總結的時候
他就會適時而出現的
第三個 我們剛剛在信件里面看到這個總結這封郵件對不對
但是
你會注意到在gmail的右上角這邊會出現這個向Gemini來提問的這個按鈕
所以你可以點這個提問按鈕
然後 你就可以跟他說
請幫我草擬信件
拒絕這次課程外派 送出
所以他會讀你現在正在看的這個信件的內容
然後
感謝邀請跟信任 首先考慮行程沖突這東西啊
我們發現幾個有趣的狀況就是 第一個就是 周先生是誰
就是他的這個回覆生成他在抓你的來源資料的時候
他其實抓的有一點不太穩定
如果一次就中 那當然你就可以直接按那個信件回覆
然後你就可以直接按插入
他就會幫你把他的這個生成的內容直接插入到你的草稿里面的
就可以快速做一些調整跟修正
這個功能其實我覺得 如果寫英文性的話真的非常非常好用
但是中文的部分就是你可能是要稍微檢查一下 他還是會有幻覺的產生
那如果你到現在還沒有看到這個Gemini的星星
那不要懷疑
那你應該有是AB測試的問題 所以應該就是時間會解決這個問題
這不是你個人的問題
接下我們進雲端印碟里面的 這個雲端的word的這個文件打開文件之後
一樣你會在右上角這邊看到這個Gemini的星星出現
那你就可以點開這個星星
我們剛剛已經試過文字生成了
那這一次我們來挑戰看看圖片生成
眾所皆知Gemini的網頁版也是可以做到圖片生成的
那比如說我們今天要在文件里面插入一台車子的封面圖
幫我生成一張
帥氣的車子的報告封面
完成 給了你4張
然後我們就可以直接把這個圖扔進去
點一下 沒問題好
然後按插入
他就可以直接參與插入到這個報告里面
所以之後你在Google文件里面然後再去撰寫那些報告的時候
如果你真的臨時馬上想到 我需要一張圖片的時候
這時候你就可以叫Google Gemini來幫你生成一張圖片
就我目前的已知的資訊他應該是跟adobe
還有他們有自己的圖像模型
現在他到底是用哪一個模型去生成的就要猜
就是我已知他有兩個訊息
就是一個是他們會跟adobe合作用adobe的fire fly的這個圖像生成模型
可是最近google他們其實也有他們google自己的fast的模型
如果沒有記錯的話
所以其實google也有自家的圖像生成模型
那現在這個功能是用他們自家模型做的還是用adobe的模型做
其實我們不得而知 但總之
你在做google文件的時候
你就可以快速的去生成一些漂亮的插圖插到這個圖像里面去
第五個呢
在Google的slide里面
其實你應該也會跟我一樣非常的好奇
就是Gemini進到Google slide里面能夠做到什麽事情
那一樣現在你在Google slide的這個編輯的畫面 比如說我們這個同事
剛剛做了一份簡單的啊這個GPT跟Gemini的簡報
可是呢
有些頁面
像這個沒有做的很好怎麽辦呢
這時候我們就在這個頁面里面
然後你就可以直接點右邊的這個星星向Gemini來提問
或者是呢
你可以點選你的選單這邊有一個功能叫做幫我製作投影片
或者是你可以在插入里面找到同樣的功能叫做幫我製作投影片
那我們就點下去
你今天需要什麽協助
你就直接把提示語留在這邊
就5個字 不要亂加 我們試過很多奇奇怪怪的提示語
但是一旦改了這5個字 製作投影片 這5個字只要我們一改掉
他就不會制作了 我不知道為什麽但總之我們跑跑看
有了 好 然後插入你就獲得了一個新的頁面
但是那個背景消失了 我們獲得一張圖
標題文字內容基本上就是根據你原本這些東西來去做這樣的一個生成
那當然你會需要花點時間排版
但是這已經比之前的Google slide好用多了
之前Google slide他只會根據你的來源的文字生成圖片
他現在多了生成文字跟圖片
比如說我們可以針對這個內容
給我一頁簡報說明
好
再這樣子 那我們就來簡單的從一份新文件開始
那我們就隨便來點字
比如像這樣你把你要做的東西丟進去之後就跟他說制作投影片
做出來啦
你就直接按插入
他就可以快速的幫你把一大堆你原本要整理的大量的這些資料
然後快速的幫你整理成一份簡報的形式
而且幫你配上一個插圖
這個就是目前Gemini 他整合到Google slide里面你有機會能夠做到的事情
那自己我們有測試的時候
不同的gmail賬號其實可能他的功能跟權限會有一些些的差異
所以如果你能夠成功做出來那恭喜你天選之人
那如果你還不行 那你可能換一個gmail賬號
或者你換用公司的一些付費版的這個企業版的gmail賬號
或者是教育版的gmail賬號里面的這些權限設定
還有模型導入的前後順序可能會有點不一樣哦
再來雲端硬碟
比如我們這些影片腳本然後你點了他之後呢你可以按右鍵
然後你就可以看到這個地方叫做生成這個檔案的摘要
這也是Google Gemini在雲端硬碟的這個模式之下新出來的一個新功能
所以你看他就幫我把這個 我們的這個正片的這個腳本
看結構里面都把你整理的出來
你也可以去在這個地方去針對輸入一些提示語
去針對這份文件里面的內容去給他做提問跟互動
出來這個摘要 你還可以再把它變成另外一份新的google文件
好所以這個就是在google雲端硬碟里面去做這樣那個操作的時候呢
你就可以
又變成了另外一份文件
所以你就可以直接把過往的這些有大部分這些
舊的這些資料 可以很快速的去幫你去做一些篩選整理跟摘要
然後再把它變成一份新的雲端一點的文件呢
這個部分我覺得其實還蠻好用的
那我們自己有在測試的時候呢
我們發現如果你在雲端硬碟里面存的是圖片或者是影片
那目前這個功能是沒法用的 那我猜應該是算力的問題啊
就是雖然說Gemini是一個就是多模態
它是可以處理聲音影像文字等等的這種不同的形態內容的AI模型
可是我猜受限於算力的限制
所以他目前是沒有辦法開放影片跟聲音來去做這樣的一個影音摘要的內容
那這東西可能要去用notebookLM
我們有影片 下一個Google的試算表
那這個是我們那個去年的頻道的這些流量的一些真實數據
然後有了這個東西之後
右邊這邊你會看到一個叫做生成這個表格的摘要 沒錯又是熟悉的雙子星
點一下
那他就可以去幫你分析這個東西的摘要
那我們移到表格的下面的時候
你會看到另外一個星星又出現了 分析這項資料
你注意看 這是原本的摘要 對不對
好那我來分析這項資料
其實他這個應該就是預先幫你把那個提示語寫在這邊
所以你用直接手動輸入的方式 應該也都是會做的
那你可以觀察到他就開始生成了python的程式碼
然後試圖來去分析 OK
好他就開始分析啦
接下來 你的趨勢分析 每月趨勢分析 自動幫你做好每月趨勢分析
這個是用觀看訂閱人數的分析
觀看時間小時的分析
觀看次數的分析
不同影片長度的平均訂閱人數
影片長度5-10分鐘的訂閱人數
短片低於5分鐘大約10分鐘
不同影片長度的平均觀看時間
曝光次數跟點閱率的散佈圖
他還幫你列出了三個洞察
2024的3月份 表現的特別好
好中等長度的影片 表現更加好 曝光次數跟點擊率的並不高
那這些生成的圖片呢
如果你喜歡你就可以把這個你好不容易做好的請AI分析好這個圖片
按插入把它放到你的google試算表里面去
這樣這個圖片就會留下來
不然你重新整理一下那這個對話串就會被清空
你每次有一份新的數據
那原本你要excel在那分析東分析西
然後弄了半天自己頭很痛
現在不用你現在就是把這個丟上去然後按一下
讓Gemini這個AI最強大腦
直接幫你自動分析
自動做圖表
而且比chatGPT好的地方是呢
他的圖表不會有中文顯示錯誤的問題
這個chatGPT這塊真的做的很差
那你可能會擔心說他的這個圖表生成的內容會不會有算錯的問題
好
那其實你可以往上卷 你也可以看到說他在做這樣的一個圖表生成的時候
他的本質上其實是生成程式碼
然後去做圖像的一個數據的分析
所以他其實是AI理解你的問題
然後他去生成python的程式碼
然後再去執行
最後獲得這樣的一個數據
所以只要你的原始數據沒有錯誤
那基本上他跑出來這個圖表應該是可以去切合你的原始數據的
不會有幻覺的這個現象
所以這個是Gemini放到Google試算表里面的
這個新的功能 我個人覺得還蠻好用的
就你就不用再去學那麽多的那些什麽Excel的什麽函式
然後作圖做表弄得很頭痛
沒有你現在就是靠這個AI大腦直接幫你去做資料的分析
而且還會有洞見
那應該就可以很好的應付你的主管
我們來到了Google首頁
你說Google首頁這里面到底有什麽AI的成分呢
很簡單你可以直接在Google搜尋的時候
AI會自動幫你摘要你的搜尋的結果
這個功能叫做AI Overview
已經上線了
但是不一定每次都會通過
比如說呢
text to formula Excel相關的AI這個關鍵字好了
你就會去看他搜尋出來的結果
那就是原本的這個搜尋出來結果 代表這個關鍵字他沒有驅動
所以比如說 我們可以去搜尋小貓可以吃甜食嗎
然後 你這個地方就會看到
這個AI overview AI摘要的這個功能
他會直接去幫你搜尋網頁相關的內容
然後給你一份簡單的摘要
那這功能
說實話了就我們制作人calvin每次試每次成功
但我的賬號 我換了一堆賬號每次試每次失敗
所以如果你有遇到這個AI overview這個功能
恭喜你你也被Google選中啦
是天選之人
你可以請Gemini的這個AI去幫你 針對你提問的這個問題
先去網絡上找資料之後 給你一份這樣的一個摘要
所以這個摘要後面的這些連結 就代表說他是從這個網址去摘要出來的
所以你就可以去點這個網址的來源資料
然後回去看一下當初到底發生了什麽事情
所以這個是Gemini躲在Google搜尋里面 那我們可以看得到
google其實也很認真的要應對這一波來勢洶洶 來自chatgpt的搜尋
perplexity或者是這些其他的具備聯網功能的這些AI工具
生程式AI工具的一個進攻
就google而言呢
我相信他們應該也非常非常的緊張哦
因為這個畢竟是他們立國之根本 最近Sam Altman去了紅杉資本的演講的時候
他就講一個很有趣的現象
叫做中老年人像我們40歲以上的人 是把chatGPT
當Google在使用遇到問題 就可以直接問他
可是對於年輕人來說
現在他們不是直接去問Google問題
他們直接去問chatGPT問題之外 他們還會
試著把chat GDP接入他們的工作還有生活相關的這些流程里面
他們會做到比原本我們使用Google搜尋更加深入的
跟這些AI工具來做這樣一個整合
那我不知道你是怎麽看待這件事情
但是我們也可以觀察到
Google其實非常努力的想要把所有的這些Gemini AI的模型整合到
Google的方方面面的各個服務里面去
再來你可以去你的gmail賬號
Youtuber的後台叫做Youtube studio
那怎麽進來呢
去Youtube里面然後點選你的大頭照
這邊會有一個Youtube工作室
那進到這個Youtube studio Youtube工作室的後台之後
選擇內容
在內容里面有一個新的功能叫做創作靈感
在這個地方 沒錯我們又看到了熟悉的雙子星
這個功能看起來應該是Youtuber team里面他們在做
studio這邊 他們是把這個東西做進去
那傳統的做法你可以在這邊看到別人拍的什麽影片啊
那他們現在就是透過Al去推薦別人拍的什麽影片給你
那我們就可以簡單的問他比如說
如何彈鋼琴
然後就取得建議
然後就失敗了
那中文失敗 好
那你就可以說
how to play piano
那他就會給你一些這個策題的建議 那我們就隨便點一個進去
好 所以Youtuber team他們想的事情是
其實你可以在影片制作這件事情上使用Gemini來協助你做策題
所以第一你要用英文去下
但是我相信之後應該很快就會更新
然後 他就會給你吊人胃口的情節片段
他會提醒你說 有哪一些是觀眾可能感興趣的內容
或者是你的影片大綱
他會直接幫你把影片大綱整理出來
還會給你一些縮圖的建議甚至是標題的建議
然後給你相關的這些影片作為一個參考
好那還給你一些延伸的一些思路
我覺得蠻有趣的 它是直接系統級的來去試圖
協助你在做策題這個方向
他就不是直接在來來回回的對談之中 然後把很多很多事情來回問半天
他現在是直接一個指令就直接給你整支影片你會用到的包含縮圖的參考
標題的參考內容大概的參考
甚至是如何去創造一個吸引人來觀看的YouTube的影片的一些小秘訣
好那我覺得這個技術還不錯
就是你可以自己就去規劃如何去教會別人
因為YouTube它本質上就是想要別人願意看
所以你要去如何去吸引別人來去觀看這支影片的一個想法跟策略
會比你直接憑空去想好來的簡單許多
最後一個
我們要談的是在Google Meet里面 那比如說我們進去Meet.Google .com之後呢
來隨便點一個Google的這個視訊會議
那進這個會議之後 我們立即加入
加入之後 你會看到右邊這邊有一個讓Gemini進入這場會議的內容
他會自動的幫你去記錄這個會議里面的內容
然後他會把這個會議記錄的連結會直接幫你加到這個google日歷活動
還有google雲端硬碟里面
然後他會使用所選的語言比如說英文 你可以變更
那可惜的是呢
他現在只有日文西班牙法文英文意大利葡萄牙德文跟韓文 還不支援中文
我們做了一個簡單的測試
他會幫你 針對你的會議日期
然後會有一些那個 你這個google日歷的這個副本然後你的逐字稿
然後幫你做摘要
然後細部的東西
然後會標注那個你什麽時候討論什麽事情好然後誰講的什麽話
然後他會建議你之後可以做的事情然後next step
然後他就是用Google的這個Gemini來去幫你做
然後還會提醒你說哎make sure they are accurate就他不一定是完全正確的
你自己檢查一下
不過就是一邊開會然後就會一邊幫你自動做會議記錄跟摘要
你可以看到這個會議的記錄的大綱
然後他這個就是會議的這個 就是討論的這個逐字稿
那我們自己看呢基本上就是英文他聽懂沒有問題 但是中文他就亂聽
所以呢
這可能要等到他正式支援中文之後你才能夠獲得這個非常完美的東西
好那至少我知道最近做會議記錄這件事情 像notion AI最近有更新
那聽說做的還不錯 不過還沒時間試
當然我們gogole都花錢了 所以如果之後像google能夠正式支援中文的話呢
那我們當然會毫不猶豫的拋棄notion然後回到google的懷抱
所以我覺得這個也是時間的問題
搞不好影片上架的那一天就已經支援中文也說不定
以上就是我們這一集啊我們盤點的
在Google的服務里面我們找到了10個Gemini躲藏的小位置
那不知道你對於這個Gemini他深入到整個Google的服務里面去的想法是如何
但是AI會離我們的工作跟生活越來越近
這應該是一個不可逆的趨勢
希望你喜歡今天的影片
那我們今天就到這個地方
如果你喜歡的話麻煩幫我們分享給更多的朋友
還有別忘了按讚訂閱分享開心小叮當我們是泛科學院
下次影片再見嘍拜拜